Muun muassa kaupassa käviä tässä hyvää päivää Kansanratio. Asiat eivät ole koskaan niin huonosti, ettei niitä voisi vielä pahentaa.
Kerta kaikkiaan tuo on mennyt kummaksi tuo kaupassakääntikon. Pitäisi älypuheli olla, että saa kaupasta kahvia tai ruokaa, niin kaikki pitää aktivoida koko ajan. Kuka hiivatti niitä kerkiää jatkuvasti näppäillä sen puhelimen kanssa? Onkohan täältään muutakin tekemistä tässä maailmassa, kun räpätään yhtä puhelinta ja älypuhelinta menee ostamaan koskaan. Ja jos se siihen kaatuu, että älypuhelin pitää ostaa,
niin kuolen tänne koti ilman ruokaa. Kiitosta ja hei. - Ei ole soittaja läheskään ainoa ihminen tällä pallolla, jota tuo asia sapettaa. Nopeasti kun aiheesta etsii, niin tulee aika paljon vastaan juttuja, eikä pelkästään Suomesta, jossa toivotaan, että olisipa kiva taas käydä kaupassa ilman, että koko ajan pitää huzerata puhelimella. Erityisesti se olisi mukava, että jos on alennukset, niin ne olisivat sitten -
kaikille eikä vaan sovelluksen omaaville. Se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdy.
Lokkien kirkuminen se tarkoittaa että kevät on saapunut pian alakerran baarin terassilla kun öisin kirutaan niin se puolestaan tarkoittaa että sitten kesä on saapunut mutta mennään vuodenaika kerrallaan.
Joskus on tänne Kansanradioon tullut sellainen puhelu jossa harmitellaan että miksi mainoksia tulee vaikka ovessa lukee että ei mainoksia. No tällä kertaa puolestaan harmitellaan sitä kun niitä mainoksia ei tule vaikka olisivat hyvin toivottuja ja harmittelusta puheen ollen se on kuulemma tylsää kun potkitaan pois keskusteluryhmistä vaikkei siellä ole mitään sääntöjen vastaista tehnyt mutta nyt jatketaan kauppakierrosta ja lounaallakin käydään.
Yleensivuiltani täällä lukee että Ruotsissa ruuan hinta laskee keskiviikkona kun sen arvonlisälisävero puolitetaan kuuteen prosenttiin. Asiantuntijan mukaan Suomella ei ole varaa vastaavan alennuksen heikon julkisen talouden vuoksi. Oisko se se Suomen hallitus taas joka on taas munannut. Voi herjantaa ei voi voi voi voi.
Yleensivuiltani täällä lukee että Ruotsissa ruuan hinta laskee keskiviikkona kun sen arvonlisälisävero puolet taas kuulee. Asiantuntijan mukaan Suomella ei ole varaa vastaavan alennuksen heikon julkisen talouden vuoksi.
Miehiä yksi työmies oli siellä joka puhui puhelimessa ja tuli pois sieltä työmaalta että mä ihmettelen että onko se työnjohtaja lomalla vai missä se on kun siellä koko toinen tien puoleen ja se iso tien puoleen ovi on ollut jo kuukausi kaupalla suljettuna. Kiitos.
Ostoskeskuksessa isossa ostoskaupassa tuli paha mieleen kun heti meni sisään niin tulee surkuttelevaan musiikkiin niin kuin meni hautajaisiin että minua ei kiinnostanut enää ostaa mitään että olisi ollut kivempiin vähän sellaista kivaa musiikkiin että olisi se ostosreissuki sujunut paremmin. Itse sääli musiikki joka paikassa.
On tämmöisiä ravintolot jotka eivät tunnista sitä onko ihminen diabeetikko tai epilepsia sairastava ja ravintoloitten henkilökunta soittaa poliisit koska tarvitsisi soittaa ambulanssi tai kyllä pitäisi kouluttaa näitä ravintoloitten henkilökuntaa tunnistamaan.
Onko ihminen humalassa vai onko hänellä jonkinlainen kohtaus. Ei tässä muuta. Meille saapuvista sähköposteista yksi alkaa että ottaa päähän kun koko ajan vouhkataan bensan hinnasta vaikka dieselin hinta on noussut enemmän kuin bensan hinta.
Bensan hintaa toitotetaan eduskunnassa uutisissa A-studiossa ja vielä puoli seitsemässäkin. Kun mietitään mitä liikkuu dieselin voimin niin kannattaisiko kuitenkin dieselin hinnasta vouhkata enemmän. Tosin jos ei halua painottaa kumpaakaan voisi vaan puhua polttoaineen hinnasta. Pitkän matkan linja autot rekat kuorma autot ja valtaosa pakettiautoista kulkee dieselin voimin. Dieselin hinta vaikuttaa ruuan hintaan enemmän. Viestin on alle kirjoitettu.
Faktapohjaista keskustelua haluava Raumalainen. Rauman jälkeen vuoroon Sumiainen nyt seuraa paikallisraportta ja Tampere on tällä viikolla erityisen hyvin edustettuna mutta meidän aloituspaikka löytyy nyt keski-Suomesta.
Kansanradiotervehdys. Vanha ihminen täällä Sumiaisissa asun. Minulle tuli Traficomilta tämmöinen tutkimus. Minkälainen tutkimus tuli Traficomilta? Tervetuloa mukaan elinympäristösi kehittämiseen.
No niin. Liikenne- ja viestintävirasto kehittämässä elinympäristöäsi. Niin kuka tämmöisen rahoittaa kun tätä ajetaan alas koko Sumiesten kyllä? Täältä hävintyt terveyskeskus, kaikki palvelut. Nyt vanhainkoti menee yksityiselle. Ei tätä kehitetä. Ei tätä Traficomkaan varmaan kehitä. Mitä siinä tarkemmin sitten lukee siinä? En mä oo avannut koko kuoria kun mä en mua kiinnosta.
Mutta tämmönen kun rahaa pannaan tämmöiseen asiaan mikä ei varmaan johaa mihinkään. Sumiainen sen alueen vointi ei tällä hetkellä mikään paras mahdollinen. Näin sanoit. Ei se oo tämmönen mitä tässä yritetään tätä kehittää. Tätä ajetaan vähän huonommaksi koko ajan. Palvelut katoaa ja mikä palvelu mielestäsi jää puuttumaan sumiaisintaan? Tärkeimpi ja kai nyt niin kuin minäkin oon jo seitsemän vitoinen.
Niin että nuo terveyspalvelut olis ollut tuossa tuo terveys. Sinne saa käyvät näytteet laittamassa ja jat joulut menee tuonne äänekoskelle kolmekymmentä kilometriä. Äänekoskelle asti joo. En mä mäe sinne enää ollenkaan. Mulla on tuossa vedenpanemittaria, veden sokerimittaria ja muuta jos missä ei mitään on. Mitä mä nyt? Ihan mielenkiinosta ehkä avaisin vielä sen Traficomin kirje ja lukisin mitä kaikkea siellä on.
Mä oon näitä avannut kaksi. Tuli ensimmäisenä en vastannut enkä toiseenkaan niin kolmatta ei ole tullut ollenkaan. Tajusivat että sinne on turha lähetellä kun ei. Kyllä mä aika useasti vastaan tuommoisiin kaikkiin mutta johtaako hän ikinä tuommoiset systeemit mihinkin? Jokuhan niistä Leepässä saa tietysti se tekee tämmösiä tutkimuksia. Sumiaisen kylässä ei ei ei siis palvelut sillä tasolla kun pitäisi olla. Minä kiitän kun soitit tänne tästä. Selvä kiitoksia. Kiitos.
-Päivä jatkuu. -Moi. -Nimimerkki helpolla rahaa. Minä olen hämmästynyt kun asun täällä Helsingissä ja mainoksia ei enää nykyään enää jaeta kuulta taikka siis ne pitäisi jakaa mutta niitä ei jaeta. Tässä on aika helppo homma saada rahaa itselleen käy hakemassa. Tässä on Jyskin mainokset ja sit on Pulversin mainokset. Niin niin.
Ne ottaa jaetavaksi ja sitten ne kantaa ne mainokset roskiin ja sitten he saavat taas rahat sitten firmasta.
Harmittaa kun joskus siellä oli semmoisiakin tuotteita mitä haluais ostaa. Itselläni ei ole älypuhelinta eikä tietokonetta.
Että kaikki tämmöset mitä jos haluat ostaa tai olet kaivannut niin ne on niin kuin mainosten takana että tiedät että voit mennä ostamaan silloin ja silloin.
Mutta en ymmärrä tämmöistä systeemiä et eikö firma tota minkäännäköistä kontaktia siitä että jaetaanko ne vai meneekö ne suoraan roskiin. Tällainen uutinen mulla oli tässä.
-Mä jatkan. Viilin syömistä nyt. Heippa. -Tässä on eräs mummu Tuusulasta. Ihmettelen Tuusulan touhuja. Rakennetaan jotain puolentoista metrin lankkupolkuja tuonne pitkin mettiin ja rantaviivoille luantopolkuja.
Niin se ei saa ees kulkea heinäkuuhun vai elokuuhun asti. Ne on kielletty ylit. Lillut häiriintyy mutta vanhuksille ei ole sen edes ruokakauppaan apua että kävivät ruokakauppassa tai kävivät tuollaisiin jotain ruokaa oventaakkeen edes. Sitten ihmetellään mihin rahat kuluu. Ne ei ole mitään halpaa. Puolentoiskilometrin pätkiä tämmöisiä jotain lankkupolkuja tuonne järverantaa rakennetaan.
Ihmettellä täytyy kyllä tätä touhua. Kiitos, näkemiin. -Tommi Yläjärveltä tässä. Olen tehnyt tässä nyt reilu kaksi vuotta kotihoidossa hommia lähihoitajana Tampereella ja tota mä ihmettelen ihan hirveesti tämmöstä ilmiöä että ihmiset jättää valoissa semmoisia niinku auton mentäviä jopa pidempiä välejä siihen edellä olevaan auton.
joka seisoo punasissa. Et eiks nää ihmiset ymmärrä että ne tuottaa ruuhkia silleen että ihmiset jotka tuovat heidän takaansa ja yrittävät jollekin kaistalle joka kääntyy vasemmalle niin ne ovatkin siellä jonossa eivätkä pääse siihen vihreeseen valoon ja niin poistaa. Et mikä ihmeä juttu tää on että ihmisillä on ajatus jostain turvavälistä valoissa. Se turvaväli pätee vaan siellä liikenteessä kun sitä kun se auto liittyy.
- Että tällaista. Hyvää kevättä, moro. - Joo, JKH Tampereelta. Olisi taas hyvä ehdotus. - Olisi taas hyvä ehdotus. - Osaatko kuunnella edelleen sujuas? Sähtöpotkulaudosta Tampereella ja muualle kauheasti moititaan, että kun ne on se miesää, niin ei kukaan saa käyttää eikä saada sitä kuriin.
Minulla on taas kerran hyvä huumoripohjainen ohje. - Ja me otamme JKH:n huumoripohjainen ehdotus vastaan hyvin mielellämme. Anna tulla.
Että kuuttimonumentti eli sähköpotkulautamonumentti. Eiks sehän ole aika hyvä huumoripohjainen idea? - Kaikki skootit kerätään kasaan, niistä tehdään skoottimonumentti. - Se tehdään erittäin julkiselle paikalle kauhean, niin kuin Tampereella, jos nyt on Koskipuisto aika sinne keskein, niin ne voisivat täällä kerätä Koskipuisto kun se on se kivipatsas, niin sinne lähelle kaikki ja hitsataan ne yhteen toisiinsa ettei niitä saa irti ja se päällekirjoitus.
Kuuttimonumentti tai sitten toinen vaiheessa on se sähköpotkulautamonumentti. - Niin siis monumentti niiden muistoille. Nytkö ne ei enää terrorisoi meidän katuja? - Just näin. Hyvä sua. Sää on hyvin mukana. - Ei niin hitailla vaikka sunnunta onkin. - Jokuhan ehdotti, mutta se oli vaan radio ohjelma sekä siitä se enempää, mutta mikä kaupunki on ensimmäinen joka uskaltaa lopettaa koko sähköpotkulautan esille.
tuomisen keväällä ja se se mutta taitaa olla olla olla ihan ympäri ympäri maailma toi sama keskustelu sinne siis kaikki yhteen isoon pinoon nähdäänköhän me sitten vähän huonotuulisia ja epätoivoisia nuoria jotka yrittää repiä niitä sieltä irti mainio juttu hei hei tampereelle oikein hyvät päivät monumentin paikkaa suunnittelemaan no nimenomaan just näin joo päivä jatketaan skootin keskustelu no se nyt ainakin on
kevään merkki, mutta joko se on alkanut vai onko se mennyt minulta vaan tällä kertaa ohi? Tuntuu siltä, että tällä hetkellä tulee vastaa niin isoa, merkittävää ja poikkeuksellistakin uutista, että ihan kaikkia asioita ei kerkeä edes kunnolla rekisteröimään. Suomen puolelle lentäneet droonit, ne veivät ja vievät ymmärrettävästi palsta tilaa. Ukrainan sodastakin meille saapui yksi puhelu.
- Jo tuultani Nurmelan Kalevi Kokkolasta, hyvää päivää. - Mitäpä kuuluu tänä sunutana? - No minä olen tänään sitä asiaa, että kun neljä miljardia, siis neljä tuhatta miljoonaa ja siellä aseita on laitettu Ukrainan, että kyllä me tarvittaisiin ne rahat itsekin, että eihän sitä nyt tuota ja niillä sitten tapetaan venäläisiä. Se on lähin naapurikin ja mistä tämä sota alkoikin selskin, niin tuota leikataan?.
Lentokonella lentäjä kerjää rahat ja me polose täällä Suomesta pitää rahoittaa tuota, että tuo aivan järjityttä hommaa, tuommoiset rahamäärät annetaan ja sitten se ajaa eteen niskaan näitä rooneja, jos on muitako, niin meidän rahoilla sinne rahoitetaan tuo. Se on niin valtavan summan raha, että sillä paljon köyhät, siis lääkärihoitoja. - Sanoit tuossa aikaisemmin, että mistä se sot alkoi?.
Se sotakin alkoi, niin mistä se sota alkoi?.
Se alkoi sitten kun justit me selskin valittiin ja se oli niin länteen ja Nato on Kallella, että oli se maa- ja sehän on Venäjä alue, että siellähän oli se Sernevoilit sun muulta, niin vähän erilaista systeemiä pitäneet, mitä pitivät. Ne oli jo niin länteen menossa, niin ihan Venäjä tuomosta hyväksyi ja sehän on Venäjä alue, että Ukraina.
- Ukraina siis kuuluu Venäjälle?. - Se kuuluu sinne. Sitä ei tarvitse olla itsenäinen, että näitä Viroliettoa ja Latviakin ei saisi irtää. Kaikki kans lyö Venäjään, ne kuuluu Venäjään. - Eikö tässä sitten Suomi?. - Suomi?. Tässä nyt ollaan, mutta se on nyt justi sama kuka tämänkin omistaa. Täällä köyhet lyövät niin ahtaalle, mutta kun rikkaalle annetaan ja köyhiltä viedään ja sosiaaliturva on niin pantu ahtaalle, että täällä on tällä hetkellä, kun täällä on.
Tämä kokoomus on ihmispiru. - Mutta miten siis sitä vielä kysyin, että miten sitten Suomen suhde Venäjä, kun sanoit Ukraina Venäjälle ja Baltian maat Venäjälle?.
Viettyä tovaraa niin paljon, kun olisi pystytty ja keretty täältä niin kauppaa tehdä Venäjän kanssa.
- Minä kiitän, että soitit Kansanradioon. - No joo, mutta kun ne ovat sensuurit, niin sillä ei panna läpi vaan läpi, että kansa kyllä ne monikin näin ajattelee. Ainakin ne tulevat minulle sanomatta. Hyvä Kalevi.
- No niin, me kuullaan. Kiitos, hei. - Kiitos, moi.
Myös näihin toisenlaisiin puhelimme onko se vaan niin, että niihin älypuhelimien tulee vaan niitä varoituksia, että miten käy meijä, joilla on tämmöinen tavallinen puheli, että eipä tässä muuta ja hänpä oottelee. Kiitoksia, kiitoksia.
Troni tulee Suomen rojesiselle, ei mitään tiedotusta. Pitääkö laajentaa kotivakuutosta troonien varautta ja Suomi mukaan varautunut hyökkäyksiin? Paskaton. Vilanomaiset salaa tärkeitä asioita kansalta. Morjes.
Pääsee nimenomaan tämmöisiä kroonia tuosta rajan ylitteettä. Mitä sitten, jos Troni se oikein sota, niin nehän tulee sieltä kun Lonto on sumusta, että jos tuommosekin pääsee nivahtamaan. Ja kyllä minä vähän heppäilettäkään. Siinä on Venäjän sormet pelissä, että siellä Puttini huitoo tuolla leipällä piola tuossa rajan pinnassa, että menkää, menkää vaan Suomen puolelle ne roonit. Että tämmöistä vähän heppäällä aina sappii kyllä. Toivotaan, että ne vähän sais enempi ohjattua niitä roonit.
Venäjällä niitä saisi tulla vaikka enemmänkin ja mieluummin sinne Puttinin punkkeriin vaikka pudottaa joku siitä ilmastointiputkesta. Eipä tässä muuta. Moro.
No Vesa täällä. Tervehdys. Semmoinen asia kiinnostaa kun nyt tuota taivaalta putoita kaiken sotaromulla Suomen alueelle. Minkälaisia korvauksia saa ihmiset jos tulee taloon, auton päälle, mökin päälle, ihmisten päälle?
Ja jos vakuutus on kunnossa, esimerkiksi autossa täyskasvun vakuutus, niin kuka korvaa? Onko vakuutusyhtiöllä mitään korvausverotuksia tämmöisessä asiassa vauhtia olla vai kuka mahtaa tehdä korvauksia? Ei muuta. Kiitti. Siinähän me päästiin taas kysymysten makuun. Antaa tulla seuraavaksi lisää kysymyksiä hyvin monipuolisesti eri aiheista. Meille on Kansanradion lomakkeen kautta tullut muun muassa tällainen viesti, jossa kysytään, että miksi ihmeessä ihmisten pitää lentokoneella tulee korvausverotuksia?.
Laskeutuessa ja usein istuinvyövalon vielä palaessa rynnätä pystyyn kahmimaan matkatavaroitaan hyllyltä. Sitten seistään ahtaalla käytävällä omien lalkkujen kanssa hikinen ahteri ja kaksi viikkoa pesemättä olleet shortsit vielä istuvan naaman edessä. Tämä ryysiminen ei säästä kenenkään aikaa, sillä yleensä myös istujat nousevat omalla vuorollaan. Toisin sanoen viisitoista minuuttia turhaan seissyt matkustaja ei pääse koneesta yhtään sen nopeammin kuin koneessa.
Sitten toinen kummallisuus on matkatavaroiden poimiminen liukuhihdalta. Arvioisin, että huomattava enemmistö väestä pakkautuu edelleen kiinni kuljetushihnan viereen, estäen muilta kaiken näkyvyyden tuleviin matkatavaroihin. Yleisesti täytyy todeta, että nämä kyseiset toimintamallit eivät ole vain suomalainen kummallisuus, vaan koskee kaiken maalaisia, kaiken ikäisiä miehiä ja naisia, herroja ja duunareita. Me suomalaiset olemme monessa asioissa. Esimerkiksi Suomessa.
Se on erittäin esimerkillisiä. Miksemme voisi toimia esimerkkinä järkevyydestä muille myös lentokoneesta poistuttaessa ja lentokentällä matkatavaroita noudattaessa. Terveisinä nimimerkki Eino Mutku.
Seurakunnista. Siellä on semmoinen kuin sururyhmä. Miksei sinne oteta kaikkia? Siellä hyvin voimakkaasti valikoidaan kenet otetaan siihen ryhmään. Minutkin ajettiin pois vaikka minä menin sinne. Vaikka olin varmasti enemmän ehkä suruissaan kuin moni muu. Tämmöistä on ympäri Suomen sururyhmäseurakunnalla.
Tämä ei ole mikään sururyhmä. Koirillekin pidetään sururyhmää, joka on minusta aika hävytöntä. Kiitos. - Kun televisiossa mainostetaan katsoareenasta, katsoareenasta. No missä minun telkkaristani ei löydy semmoista kanavaa kuin areenaa? Mitä se oikeastaan tarkoittaa? Onko tämmöiselle vanhalle eläkelää?
sille jotain ohjeita, että miten voi katsoa areenaa. Tää on se, että tässä muuta sitten. Moi.
Miksi heidän pitää kuitenkin kiskoossa sama hinta siitä, sit kun se myysivät se suoraan. Toinen kysymys, jos kerran on olemassa tätä niin sanottua kinkkurasvasta tehtyä polttoainetta täällä Suomessa eli tätä my dieseliä tai biodieseliä, jota kyllä itsekin käytän, niin minkä takia sen hinta nousee? Jos joku öljyongelma tulee jossakin, niin miksi se nousee ihan samalla tavalla kuin nekin, jotka eivät ole näitä ekopolttoaineita? Mikä sen perustelee? Ja sitten vielä kolmas, oikeastaan se on perusasia.
Jos ihmiset haluavat kulutusta, jos hallitus haluaa, että Suomen rattaat pyörii, niin silloin pitää antaa juuri niille köyhille sitä rahaa. Pitää antaa lisää rahaa köyhille, koska ne käyttää sen. Ne pistää pyöriin. Ne luo lisää työpaikoja. Ei ne ökyrikkaat mitään tarvitse. Ne laittaa ne johonkin säilöön.
Ihan tämmöistä pilvistä. Nehän hän haluaisi vain tuo Elias Paakkanen, mikä on ykköse säästä kertomassa aina. Neit on monta. Semmosta ihan jää ketkä ei halua Elias Paakasta. Elias Paakkanen fannikerho. Mahtavaa näköjään. Hän on ykkönen ylinveto.
Mikä Eliaksessa on? Hän on aina niin huolikeltu ja aina hyvin pukeutunut ja hän on sulattanut monet meidän syrjämme. Minä uskon että Eliaksenkin sydän sulaa kun kuulee että hänellä on ihan faneja. Että onkohan teillä mahdollisimman voitteko välittää Eliaksen tervoa?.
No tässähän se kansanradion välityksellä tulee. Mä soitan joku kerta taas teille kun kerrankin on ilman moneen numero mihin voin soittaa. Tottahan toki. Minä toivotan oikein hyvät päivänjatkot. Mä tosin epäilen että Eliaxella on kaikkein paras päivänjatko kun sai tällaisen puhella. Niin hyvä. Hei kiitos paljon vielä. Hei. Moikka moi. Seuraa kielen käyttöön muutamat huomautukset pääasiassa median edustajille.
Sinne median suuntaan menee myös tämä Jyväskylästä lähetetty viesti. Ensinnäkin kaupallisten radiokanavien mainoksissa hälytysajoneuvojen, sireenien ja vastaavien tehosteiden käyttö tulisi kieltää koska ne hämmentävät liikenteessä ja voivat johtaa vaaratilanteisiin. Toiseksi itsekin maantiefillaaristina minä toivon malttia ja kohteliaisuutta sekä autoilijoille että pyöräilijöille. Yhteiset ne tiet ovat ja turha siellä on kiilailla.
Ventti. Konentuu Uusulasta. Hei. Tällainen tärkeä asia opetusministeriöllä ja opettajille Suomessa. Pitäisikö lähettää jokaisen Suomen kotiin kielioppi jossa sanotaan mitä sinänsä hän tarkoittaa ja missä yhteydessä sitä pitää käyttää ja kannattaa käyttää. Tämä on mennyt ihan hulluksi. Säteet, säteet kaikki. Oli vaikka filosofian tohtori sanonut säteet. Kyllä tämä pitää syymään.
Verbin yhteydessä ei pidä käyttää sää sanaa, sinä sanaa silloin kun se ei ole totta. Kiitos että sain hoittaa ja puhua. Hei hei.
Tarkkaat kuulijat emme ole sinun rakkaitasi. Huoma vaihtapuhetyyli. Kiitos kun tuossa televisiossa ja radiossa ja kaikissa missä sitä nyt on ihmiset puhumassa niin ne ei puhu selvällä kielellä että kirjaimet ja kaikki olisivat selvää että siitä sais jotakin.
Siis otettua. Mitä se tarkoittaa kun se on tällasta rohina ja jota ei tiedä niin ei tällaista puhetta saa olla. Se pitää olla selvää. Kirjaimet kaikki tulla oikeassa järjestyksessä että siitä ihmisessä kaikki saa selvää ettei se vene sellaisen röööö vaan eikä mitään muuta ja se on Mikko tarkoittaa.
kun tällaista kuin soittelee, ei muuta ei. - Vielä keretään kuuntelemaan muutamat puhelut tämänkertaisen jakson loppuun, luvassa sellaisia puheluita joissa jostain asiasta ilmoitetaan. Kyllä jämpti on näin. Se asia minkä sinä haluat jakaa mikä tahansa asia on sinun mielestä jämptistä juuri tietyllä tavalla niin heikun vaan soitat numeroon 0800 15464. Ihmisvastaa.
paikalla kolmen tunnin ajan joka sunnun tai heti lähetyksen jälkeen. WhatsAppia jos haluat mieluummin käyttää niin 044 5515464 ja kirjettä osoitteeseen Kansanradio pl 7 9900 24 Yleisradio.
kansan.radio.at/yle.fi. Ja nyt se on sitten osa aika hajamielisen Lasse Olkinuoran aika kiittää kun olit seurana ja hei kiitos paljon jos myös osallistuit laittamalla viestiä. Kohtahan se on muuten tuo lämpömittari niissä lukemissa että voi mennä jäätelökioskille ja ostaa sieltä jäätelön ja istua alas ilman että tulee kylmä ja siinä samalla sitten ehkä todeta ääneen että ai miten mukava kun tämä kevät ja ai miten mukava kun kohta työ.
Myös tuo kesä. Se jäätelöhän on tietysti Lakritsi jäätelöä koska Lakritsi on paras jäätelömaku. Oikein hyvää päivänjatkoa. Oikein hyvää vointia. Kansan.radio. Pohjois Karassa tällä ukkusoitteella. No tervehdys tervehdys me ei. Voi tervehdy vaan tervehdy. Niin sitä rupesi no soittamansa leikkauksesta kun jutun mieleen kun miksei eduskunnassa voisi leikata kansa kun tota se mennään haltion tällä osun kuralla niin sieltä leikata kansa. Mitä sieltä kirjaimellisesti niin kun kirjaimellisesti.
No kyllähän niitä on melkein puolesta siltä kantaedustajia taas poikkean. Kato kun sillä on tyhjiä se lakunkanto jo minun mielestäni kun nyt tätäkin kyselytuntia aina kun katon niin sillä nyt tekee tätä läppärillä omia hommia ennenkaan kuunnellekään mitä siellä puhuttaa. Ja sitten toinen juttu vielä kun niillä on ne helvetin hyvät eduun kun se soppeetimusraha kun ne saapii kaksi kautta kun ni sen saapii nii soppeetimusraha vielä niin kenellä työläisillä on semmoisia eduja ei kenellä. - Mitäköhän sanoo sitten kansanedustajana oleva tai kansanedustajana ollut tuohon
että sieltä otettaisiin sata pois. Ani kahdeksankymmentä niin se vielä jäi se se puoluetkaro rajaa jäi siinä niin se ei vielä jäi yhelle pulloon mitenkään se valta siellä. Se jaakkoi ihan päivälle vielä samalla tavalla se pulvuihoma.
- No niin siinä kaksi muutosta josta aloitetaan. Hyvä kun soitit Kansanradiaa. - Joo kiitos, kiitos kaikille. - Oikein hyvät päivänjatkut. - Moi. - Kiitos, hei.
Päivänräsästä puolusti hyvin ala-arvosta juttua Suomen sananvapaudesta verrattu jopa Stalinin aikaisiin mainoihin. Suomessa on hyvä sananvapaus, ehdottoman hyvä. Me voidaan kaikkia asioita olla eri mieltä eikä me jouduta minkä syytteisiin, että se on ihan kai maailmankärkisyö olemassa tasa-arvossa. Mutta tämä korkean oikeuden päätös, siitähän päivänräsästä ei.
Ei tuomittu uskonnon takia, vaan hänen henkilökohtaisen juttuen takia kun todettiin, että hän on lääkäri, hänen pitäisi tietää mistä homous johtuu. Ja kuitenkin homot ei voi itselle mitään. Se tulee jostain vaan ne jutut, että joku on homo ja joku ei ole homo. Ja tästä tuomio tuli, mikä oli minun mielestäni aivan oikein tästä sananvapaudesta.
- Päivänräsen Tuomio, moi. - No sattus että Martti täältä terveellys siellä joku Stubbia arvosteli, arvosteli ja haukkui niihin. Mä tätä arvostelijaa niin kun kehottaisin käymään kuuden vuoden päästä presidentti ehdokkaaksi. Ja saako enemmän kuin kaikkia tuomioita.
Kaksi ääntä. Ei muuta, hei hei.
No Lapinukko soittaa nyt, että kyllä tämä netti homma on mennyt aivan mittään.
Siillä muutellaan ihmistä kirjoituksia ja lähetellään vaatimuksia, että joiltakin mitään minultakin esimerkiksi en saa kirjoittaa mitään.
Oliko se kaheksantoista päivää vai mitä se oli?
Minä en koskaan kirjoille en tuhu rumia kun olen raivoraitis mies enkä kuitenkaan ole raivau. Nyt on taas mulle eilen tuli ja minä en saa avata Facebookia. Minä en saa vastata mihin. Kun mies on melkein kahdeksankymmentä niin ei välttämättä hallitti näitä valituksia, kurituksia, huolituksia. Sun on joskus mieleen, että netti on hyvä mutta toisaalta se on huono. Elikkä asia on aina kaksi puolta, hyvä ja huono puoli.
Mutta eipä se mitään kun minä en netillä elämään ruoalla. Hei hei.